[Musik]
>> SALLY: Bonjour tout le monde!
Aujourd'hui je vais faire un dessert.
Et le dessert est un
Paris-Brest dessert.
Oui.
Heute gibt es Französisch.
Früher konnte ich es besser.
Hallo! Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein französisches Dessert.
Das nennt sich Paris-Brest-Dessert.
Und es wurde erfunden von
– einen Moment –
Louis Durand.
Und der hat gelebt in Maisons-Laffitte.
Ich kenne nur Maisons du Monde,
aber Maisons-Laffitte.
Und zwar ist das
– und ich konnte früher echt gut Französisch sprechen.
Denn ich hatte acht Jahre Französischunterricht an der Schule.
Oui, oui.
Je parle français un peu.
Denn den Rest habe ich vergessen.
Ich weiß nur noch: Arthur est un perroquet.
Das heißt: Arthur ist ein Papagei.
Et tu es belle.
Du bist schön.
Et j'ai vingt...
J'ai vingt-neuf ans.
Das ist so die wichtigste Information,
die ihr über mich wissen müsst.
Bedeutet: Ich bin 29.
Lacht nicht!
Also heute gibt es ein französisches Dessert.
Und zwar besteht es aus
– es sind so kleine Teilchen,
man kann es aber auch als große Torte machen.
Und zwar ist das aus Brandgebäck,
also Brandteig, Brandmasse,
wird gefüllt mit einer Pralinencreme,
also mit einer Haselnusscreme.
Die mache ich auch selber.
Und das Ganze wird, glaube ich, schon ziemlich lecker.
Ich muss sagen,
zugeben, in Frankreich habe ich es nicht gegessen.
Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, wie es schmeckt.
Und im Prinzip sind auch alles nur Basic-Zutaten
und auch Basisrezepte.
Ich starte jetzt zuerst mit der Praliné.
Und zwar ist das so was Ähnliches wie Nougat.
Denn es besteht aus Haselnüssen und Zucker
und Mandeln.
Das wird karamellisiert
und dann damit später eben die Füllung gemacht.
Ich nehme dafür
200 Gramm Haselnüsse,
200 Gramm Mandeln,
280 Gramm Zucker
und 60 Gramm Wasser.
Ich könnte
– wenn ich mit dem Google Translator arbeite,
könnte ich das Video auf Französisch machen.
Aber dann müsste ich halt immer wieder absetzen,
damit ich die Wörter halt
im Kopf habe.
Na ja.
Ich werde jetzt zuerst einmal die Haselnüsse und Mandeln
einfach schön rösten,
das heißt hier in der Pfanne schwenken,
bis sie lecker duften.
Das dauert auch einen kurzen Moment.
Ihr könnt es auch im Backofen machen.
Aber ich spare mir jetzt einfach
das mit dem Backofen.
Denn hier funktioniert es auch ganz gut.
Mh.
Ich kenne noch was.
Non, rien de rien. Non, je ne regrette rien.
Hm.
>> JOSH: Kannst du das auch singen?
>> SALLY: Ich kann es auch singen, ja,
aber nicht die richtigen Töne treffen.
Nein.
Der ist wirklich schwierig, der Song.
Le
chanson.
Heißt doch Song, oder?
>> JOSH: Le chanson. Ja.
>> SALLY: Aha.
Du hast wirklich Französisch gehabt.
>> JOSH: Ja, natürlich.
>> SALLY: Wow!
Ich muss sagen, ich habe es damals nur abgewählt, weil
mein Lehrer nicht mehr so toll war.
>> JOSH: Grüße gehen raus
auch an meine Französischlehrerin.
>> SALLY: Ganz liebe Grüße
an meinen ehemaligen Französischlehrer,
der mir die französische Sprache leider versaut hat.
Ja.
Und ich muss echt sagen,
ich war...
Also ich muss schon sagen, ich war schon sprachbegabt.
Also ich habe Sprachen wirklich superschnell gelernt,
auch Englisch.
Aber bei uns auf dem Gymnasium war es so
– und deswegen bin ich auch übrigens Lehrerin geworden.
Wir überbrücken jetzt einfach mal die Zeit.
Denn guckt mal.
Ich war aber der fünften Klasse auf dem Gymnasium
bis zur dreizehnten
und wir hatten Englisch und Französisch
und nie war es einsprachiger Unterricht.
Das heißt, deine Lehrer kommen rein,
reden Deutsch mit dir, bringen dir alles auf Deutsch bei
und dann musst du nach Hause gehen
und die ganzen Vokabeln lernen.
Und ich meine:
Wie soll man lernen, eine Sprache zu sprechen,
wenn nicht mal die Lehrkraft Französisch spricht?
Und dann immer dieses stupide Vokabelauswendiglernen.
Und dann hat mich das echt...
Also so elfte Klasse habe ich gesagt:
"Nee, ich wähle Französisch ab",
obwohl ich echt gut war.
Und der hat mir außerdem damals
– das habe ich, glaube ich, schon mal erzählt.
Ich hatte einen Vortrag über
den Eiffelturm gehalten,
über la tour Eiffel.
Und dann
– es ging über Gustave Eiffel.
Und dann hat er mir eine Frage gestellt,
was mit der Freiheitsstatue in New York zu tun hat,
und hat nämlich
– und ich wusste ja, dass Gustave Eiffel
die Statue auch gemacht hat.
Und dann hat er gefragt, was da heute drin ist.
Und ich wusste nicht, dass es ein Museum ist.
Und deswegen habe ich eine Zwei gekriegt damals
für den perfekten Vortrag,
nur wegen der Frage.
Und der war so gemein,
dass ich das dann abgewählt habe.
Ja.
Und dann habe ich selber Lehramt studiert
und Englisch studiert
und habe dann am
– an der Hochschule und am Seminar.
Und da gehen jetzt liebe Grüße
an meinen ehemaligen Dozenten raus,
an den Herrn Denk, Herr Thomas Denk.
Bei dem hatte ich nämlich dann Englisch.
Und ich habe bis dahin Englisch gehasst
wegen meiner Englischlehrerin damals.
Und der Herr Denk,
der hat die englische Sprache wieder zurückgebracht,
hat mir den einsprachigen Unterricht beigebracht
und das war einfach perfekt und ich habe es geliebt.
Und dann war der Englischunterricht
so für mich als Lehrerin in der Schule
der schönste Unterricht.
Spielerisch und einsprachig den Kindern Englisch beibringen.
So muss es sein.
Okay, wir warten jetzt noch kurz.
Und jetzt sind die Haselnüsse
und die Mandeln perfekt geröstet
und ich kann jetzt das Wasser dazu gießen,
den Zucker dazu geben
und das Ganze jetzt hier einfach schön aufkochen lassen.
Das erinnert jetzt so ein bisschen an gebrannte Mandeln,
falls ihr euch an mein Video erinnert.
Und die lasse ich jetzt einfach so lange kochen,
bis das Wasser verdunstet ist.
Und dann wird das Ganze erst mal trocken
und muss dann aber noch mal weiter karamellisiert werden.
Und da müsst ihr so ein bisschen mit der Hitze spielen.
Also am Anfang nehme ich gern hohe Hitze,
damit es einfach schnell geht.
Sobald der Zucker dann trocken wird,
schalte ich aber die Hitze runter,
damit einfach das Karamell nicht verbrennt und bitter wird.
Und das Wasser habe ich jetzt hier mit dabei,
damit sich der Zucker wirklich gleichmäßig
über die Mandeln und Haselnüsse legt.
Ansonsten kann es nämlich passieren,
dass einfach alles zu schnell karamellisiert
und dann wirklich verbrennt.
Also ich zeige euch gleich die Zwischenschritte.
Jetzt schön kochen lassen, bis es trocken ist.
[Musik]
Jetzt liegt der Zucker ganz trocken um die Nüsse.
Und jetzt schalte ich den Herd ein bisschen runter
und lasse es wirklich schön langsam karamellisieren.
Das geht jetzt auch ein paar Minuten,
bis sich der komplette Zucker aufgelöst hat
und alles einfach schön glänzt.
Und dabei immer schön rühren.
[Musik]
So sieht das Ganze jetzt aus,
also schön glänzend.
Und jetzt am besten hier direkt auf so eine Backfolie streichen.
Ganz vorsichtig sein!
Denn Karamell ist wirklich superheiß.
Und jetzt lasse ich es hier einfach abkühlen
und kann es dann gleich,
sobald es abgekühlt ist, durchpürieren.
Das mache ich aber gleich,
nachdem ich die Brandmasse hergestellt habe.
Wenn ihr hier jetzt Töpfe und Pfannen habt
und da wirklich was karamellisiert habt,
bekommt ihr die am besten sauber,
wenn ihr sie mit Wasser auffüllt,
aufkochen lasst.
Und dann löst sich der Zucker und das Karamell
einfach durch das Wasser auf
und man muss gar nicht schrubben.
Also ich mache das hier kurz sauber
und richte mir dann schon mal die Zutaten
für die Brandmasse.
[Musik]
Für die Brandmasse nehme ich
60 Gramm Butter,
250 Gramm Wasser,
eine Prise Salz,
200 Gramm Mehl
und vier bis fünf Eier.
Brandteig ist auch gar nicht so schwer,
wie viele immer denken.
Ich gebe jetzt nämlich die Butter in den Topf.
Das Wasser kommt dazu.
Und die Zutaten dürfen ganz kurz kochen.
Also wirklich schön aufkochen lassen.
Wichtig ist eigentlich nur der Prozess mit dem Abbrennen.
Also nicht anbrennen, sondern abbrennen.
Und wenn die Masse dann kocht, in einem Schwung
das Mehl mit dem Salz dazu geben,
damit ein richtig schöner Teigklotz entsteht.
Es sieht am Anfang so ein bisschen falsch aus, finde ich,
weil einfach sich alles nicht so gut verbindet.
Aber jetzt schön das Mehl unterrühren.
Und jetzt ist wirklich wichtig:
Rühren und rühren,
bis sich am Topfboden ein weißer Belag bildet.
Das ist dieser Abbrennprozess.
Und dadurch verändert sich einfach
das Gluten auch im Mehl
und ich habe später eben den Vorteil,
dass der Brandteig im Ofen aufgeht
und das Mehl von außen einfach diese Gase hält
und dann alles schön luftig wird,
obwohl ich kein Backpulver brauche.
Also echt ein toller Teig.
Ich frage mich immer: Wie kann man so was erfinden?
Also so damals. Keine Ahnung.
Wie kommt man auf so eine Idee?
[Musik]
So sieht der Teig jetzt aus.
Also hier am Boden wirklich so dieser Belag,
der aber nicht verbrannt ist.
Und die Teigkonsistenz, die ist einfach
wie Knete, muss man sagen,
also so ganz anders.
Jetzt habe ich den Herd ausgemacht
und kann hier rüber.
Und jetzt könnt ihr entweder
mit einer Schüssel arbeiten
und jedes Ei gleich einzeln unterrühren
mit dem Backlöffel
oder wenn ihr sagt eure Arme sind schon überstrapaziert,
dann nehmt einfach die Küchenmaschine.
Also es geht beides oder auch ein Handrührgerät.
Denn das Unterrühren,
das ist schon noch mal echt anstrengend.
Ich fülle jetzt erst mal den Teig hier rein.
Okay,
das war jetzt nicht so elegant.
Und den Topf, den lasst ihr jetzt am besten abkühlen.
Und die Schicht am Boden, die löst sich dann ab
und das schmeckt echt wie so ein dünnes Brot.
Müsst ihr nicht mal wegschmeißen.
Das könnt ihr dann einfach so naschen.
Kennst du das noch, Josh?
Das habe ich schon mal gemacht.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aua!
Das war so heiß!
Und jetzt drücke ich den Teig
hier am Rand so ein bisschen flach,
damit er einfach schneller abkühlt.
[Musik]
Jetzt rühre ich schon mal,
dass es noch ein bisschen kühlen kann.
Und
dann gebt ihr gleich ein Ei nach dem anderen dazu.
Und normalerweise kann man es wirklich
richtig cool hier aufschlagen und reinflutschen lassen,
aber ich habe da echt so eine Phobie.
Ich muss die Eier vorher in ein Schälchen aufschlagen,
zum einen, um Eierschalen zu vermeiden,
und zum anderen kann es ja echt mal passieren,
dass mal ein schlechtes Ei dabei ist.
Und dann habt ihr euch den ganzen Teig versaut.
Ein bisschen lasse ich es noch abkühlen.
Also so, dass es nicht mehr so ganz, ganz heiß ist.
Am Anfang sieht es übrigens so aus,
als würde sich das Ei niemals mit dem Teig verbinden.
Aber rührt einfach fleißig weiter.
Es wird wirklich eine schöne homogene Masse.
So sieht die Brandmasse wirklich perfekt aus.
Man sieht schon ganz gut,
dass sie, wenn man sie so hochzieht,
einfach so schöne Spitzen bildet.
Seht ihr das?
Und die glänzt auch schön.
So muss sie aussehen.
Und einfach von der Konsistenz her nicht zu fest,
aber auch nicht zu flüssig.
Schon
– also da muss man schon
wirklich mit der Eiermenge gut haushalten.
Es kann auch sein, dass ihr mal nur ein Eigelb noch dazu gebt
statt ein ganzes Ei.
Und dann könnt ihr es einfach schön ausprobieren.
Und, wie gesagt, wenn sich diese schönen Spitzen ziehen,
dann ist sie perfekt.
Ha, so ein...
Minimal könnte hier sogar noch was dazu.
Ich glaube, ich gebe tatsächlich noch ein Eigelb dazu.
Ach!
Ich erspare mir jeden Kommentar, Josh.
Ja, dann glänzt es auch noch mal ein bisschen besser.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist sie perfekt.
Schaut ihr?
Seht ihr?
Schöne Spitze!
Und schöner Glanz.
Ich habe jetzt hier einen Spritzbeutel
und nehme da jetzt einfach zwei,
weil die Brandmasse einfach ziemlich fest ist.
Und hier vorne habe ich eine Sterntülle
mit 10 mm Durchmesser.
Und ich schlage das jetzt hier oben um.
So. Und jetzt hier einfüllen.
Brandteig gehört so zu den einzigen Teigen,
die Kinder nicht so gern naschen,
weil er halt nach nichts schmeckt,
nur so ein bisschen salzig.
Also ich habe jetzt hier einen Doppelbeutel.
Denn die Brandmasse ist wirklich sehr schwer und sehr fest
und es kann passieren, dass ein Beutel aufreißt.
Deswegen lieber doppelt.
Und hier habe ich jetzt schon Backpapier.
Auf der Rückseite habe ich Kreise aufgezeichnet
mit ungefähr 8 cm Durchmesser.
Dafür habe ich einfach hier diesen Ausstecher genommen,
den ich gleich wieder sauber machen muss.
Aber wichtig, auf die Rückseite zu malen,
damit ihr die Farbe einfach nicht auf der Vorderseite habt.
Jetzt den Spritzbeutel aufrecht halten.
Hier oben
die Hand hält ihn zu,
die andere Hand führt.
Und einfach einen Ring spritzen
Und da Brandteig einfach noch sehr gut aufgeht,
wirklich mit viel Abstand auch draufspritzen.
[Musik]
Wenn am Ende nur noch so ein bisschen Teig drin ist,
dann mache ich es ganz gerne so,
dass ich es flach hinlege
und mit einer Teigkarte darüberstreiche.
Und dann könnt ihr nämlich
alle Teigreste noch mal nach unten kratzen,
den Spritzbeutel noch mal stramm ziehen
und dann einfach den Rest noch aufspritzen.
Jetzt verquirle ich hier noch ein Ei.
Damit bestreiche ich hier die Ringe.
Und dann streue ich noch Mandelblättchen drauf.
Und durch das Ei bekommen sie einfach
beim Backen eine schöne Farbe.
Und die Mandelblättchen, die gehören halt dazu.
Das wird dann...
Das gibt dann so einen schönen Knack.
[Musik]
Da war mein Papa.
Und jetzt gerne einfach mit den Mandelblättchen bestreuen
und dann im vorgeheizten Backofen backen.
Und ich werde die Backzeit dann auch nutzen,
um schon mal die Creme herzustellen.
Und ganz wichtig bei Brandgepäck ist
– bei Brandgebäck ist,
dass die Backofentür auf keinen Fall geöffnet wird.
Und die müssen wirklich gut durchgebacken sein,
bevor ihr sie rausnehmt.
Ansonsten fallen sie nämlich wieder zusammen.
Ja.
Das wäre nicht so schön.
[Musik]
Hatschi!
Entschuldigung!
[Musik]
Dünnes Pfannenbrot.
Die Backzeit überbrücke ich jetzt, wie gesagt, mit der Creme.
Zum einen stelle ich jetzt die Praliné her.
Also ich nehme jetzt hier
die abgekühlten karamellisierten Nüsse
und werde sie einfach in einem Mixer zerkleinern.
Da ist jetzt ein Mixer wirklich auch superwichtig.
Denn so klein bekommt man sie
ansonsten einfach nicht mit einem Messer.
Dafür fülle ich die Nüsse
jetzt einfach in den Multizerkleinerer ein
und pulverisiere sie.
Und die Masse sieht jetzt so aus.
Also anfangs denkt man wirklich gar nicht,
dass aus diesem Nusspulver,
aus diesen gemahlenen Nüssen,
diese Masse wird.
Aber die ist echt geschmacklich der Hammer!
Genau. Davon wiege ich jetzt die 100 Gramm ab.
Denn die brauche ich gleich für die Creme.
Und jetzt stelle ich eine Crème pâtissière her,
also eine Konditorcreme.
Im Prinzip ist es wie eine Art Puddingbuttercreme,
nur ein bisschen andere Verhältnisse.
Dafür nehme ich
500 Gramm Milch,
60 Gramm Zucker,
vier Eigelb,
40 Gramm Stärke,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
250 Gramm weiche Butter
und, wie gesagt, 100 Gramm Praliné.
Ich gebe jetzt die Eigelbe hier in den Topf,
den Zucker dazu,
etwas Vanilleextrakt dazu,
die Stärke
und erst mal ein bisschen Milch.
Jetzt kurz klümpchenfrei verrühren.
Wenn man direkt die ganze Milch dazu gießt,
dann ist es nämlich schwieriger,
die Stärke klümpchenfrei zu verrühren.
Und jetzt einfach die restliche Milch dazu geben
und den Pudding einmal aufkochen lassen.
Das mache ich dann ganz gerne nicht bei höchster Stufe.
Denn es kommt darauf an, welchen Topf ihr habt.
Also bei mir mit dem Kupfertopf ist es wirklich so,
da kann ich den auf höchster Stufe
oder auf mittelhoher Hitze einfach erwärmen
und der Kupfertopf, der erhitzt sich gleichmäßig.
Das heißt, der Boden und die Seitenwände
werden gleichmäßig heiß.
Wenn ihr aber dünne Edelstahltöpfe habt
und dann auf volle Pulle geht, passiert Folgendes.
Der Topfboden wird zu heiß, die Wände sind kalt
und dann brennt euch die Milch und der Pudding am Boden an
und oben kocht es noch nicht mal.
Und deswegen sage ich auch meist immer,
auf mittelhoher Hitze.
Denn so brennt einfach nichts an.
[Musik]
Der Pudding ist jetzt fertig.
Denn fülle ich jetzt direkt um
in einen Teller,
damit er einfach schneller abkühlt.
Ihr könnt ihn natürlich auch im Topf abkühlen lassen,
aber es dauert einfach schneller.
Also wirklich schön flach verstreichen
und dann direkt an der Oberfläche
mit Frischhaltefolie abdecken,
– und mit direkt an der Oberfläche meine ich wirklich direkt,
also so –
damit sich keine Haut bildet.
Und ich gebe das immer ganz gern in so Emailleteller.
Denn die leiten zum einen die Hitze perfekt ab
und dadurch kühlt es einfach schneller ab.
Und jetzt muss ich eigentlich nur noch warten,
bis der Pudding abkühlt,
bis die
Törtchen abkühlen.
Und dann kann ich gleich alles zusammensetzen.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier schon weitermachen.
Wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr den Pudding hier
noch mal durch ein Haarsieb streichen
oder durch das fleißige Lieschen.
Aber der ist bei mir echt superklümpchenfrei geworden.
Daher spare ich mir das heute.
Guckt, da sind kleine Klümpchen drin.
Und die will ich nicht in meiner Creme haben.
Deswegen streiche ich es durch.
Während ich das gleich mache,
kann ich aber auch schon mal
die weiche Butter verrühren.
Die darf nämlich ganz cremig gerührt werden,
so richtig weißcremig.
[Musik]
Wenn die Butter dann ganz weich ist,
könnt ihr den Flachrührer oder Flexirührer
eintauschen gegen den Schneebesen.
Aber da muss sie wirklich schon schön weich sein.
Denn damit lässt sich das Ganze voluminös aufschlagen.
Und dann gebe ich einfach esslöffelweise den Pudding dazu
und dann noch die Praliné.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich jetzt also das Gebäck.
Und das wird jetzt einmal waagerecht aufgeschnitten.
Ganz vorsichtig.
Und dann sieht man auch schon,
wie luftig es ist!
Also richtig, richtig lecker!
>> SAMIRA: Hallo!
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Na?
Hausaufgaben erledigt?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Perfekt!
Was hattest du heute auf?
>> SAMIRA: Ich musste was im Sprachbuch machen.
Dann musste ich noch was im Arbeitsheft machen
und habe noch ein paar Sachen
für den nächsten Tag gemacht.
>> SALLY: Cool!
Voll gut!
So fleißig schon, he?
Okay.
Das habe ich schon mal erledigt.
Ich lasse auch die Deckel immer direkt drauf,
damit sich die Kreise und Kringel einfach nicht vermischen.
Dann hat man wirklich immer den passenden Deckel dabei.
Dann
kann ich die
– huch! –
diese Creme, die ich noch übrig habe,
also die Praliné...
>> SAMIRA: Kann ich das machen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Wah!
Siehst du mal, wie ich das aufgefangen habe, he?
>> JOSH: Das war echt gut!
[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Das riecht sehr halt nach Nüssen.
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> SAMIRA: Gebratene Mandeln!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SAMIRA: Und Haselnüsse.
>> SALLY: Ja, genau so.
Genau das ist drin.
Mein Gott, seid ihr Feinschmeckerkinder!
>> SAMIRA: Das riecht man nämlich.
Und vorhin habe ich ja eine Mandel
>> SALLY: Aha!
>> SAMIRA: probiert gehabt.
>> SALLY: Okay. Also Samira füllt
– warte mal, rutsch mal ein bisschen rüber –
füllt die Praliné in einen Spritzbeutel mit einer Lochtülle.
Und ich fülle die Buttercreme
in einen Spritzbeutel mit einer Blütentülle.
>> SAMIRA: Der Josh...
>> SALLY: Die Creme ist noch ein bisschen weich bei mir,
weil bei uns so Innentemperatur im Raum
ungefähr 50°C hat.
Ich hatte sie jetzt auch ganz kurz im Kühlschrank.
Aber die wird gleich im Kühlschrank fest und dann
dann passt das Ganze.
Was ist mit dem Josh?
>> SAMIRA: Der Josh
– nee. Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Der Josh hat mir vorhin erzählt,
das ist eine Spezialität
und zwar aus...
>> SALLY: Aus?
>> SAMIRA: Aus...
>> SALLY: Pa-
>> SAMIRA: -ris.
>> SALLY: Kannst du Französisch?
>> SAMIRA: Nein.
>> SALLY: Doch. Du kannst einen Satz.
Je ne
parle pas français.
Den kann, glaube ich, jeder.
>> SAMIRA: Was heißt das überhaupt?
>> SALLY: Das heißt: Ich kann nicht Französisch sprechen.
Das heißt, wenn du in Frankreich bist
und jemand spricht dich auf Französisch an:
"Bonjour mademoiselle"
und dann sagst du
– entweder kannst du antworten "Bonjour"
oder du sagst: "Je ne parle pas français."
Aber bitte rede weiter.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Sodele.
Okay. Samira, ich probiere es mal kurz aus, denn...
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Warte, warte, warte!
Das darf da unten nicht rausflutschen.
Aber ich zeige euch hier mal kurz
einmal die Lochtülle.
Das ist eine kleine Lochtülle mit 7 mm.
Okay. Jetzt probiere ich es mal.
Ich hoffe, die Creme ist jetzt nicht zu weich.
Also, wenn sie bei euch auch zu weich ist,
einfach im Kühlschrank lagern.
Jetzt erst mal eine kleine Schicht.
>> SAMIRA: Das sieht doch gut aus.
Ja, eine kleine.
>> SALLY: Dann die Füllung.
in die Mitte.
Das ist sozusagen der Kern.
Und jetzt
kommt die schöne Spritztechnik.
Ich probiere, es jetzt in so Kringeln aufzuspritzen.
>> SAMIRA: Das klappt.
Und jetzt den Deckel drauf.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Das sieht hübsch aus, gell?
Und so machen wir das jetzt.
[Musik]
Wow, Samira!
Wann bist du zur perfekten
Konditorassistentin herangewachsen?
Ich glaube, bald kann ich dir die Rezepte raussuchen
und dann machst du sie einfach.
[Musik]
Also ich habe jetzt mit der Buttercrememenge gerade mal
sieben Stück füllen können.
Also ein achtes kriege ich noch hin,
aber die Buttercrememenge
muss man auf jeden Fall verdoppeln.
Ich schreibe euch einfach
in die App und in den Blog die doppelte Menge.
Nur, damit ihr Bescheid wisst.
Denn sonst kann man die nicht so schön üppig füllen.
Und die stelle ich jetzt kurz in den Kühlschrank.
Und da werden sie fest für etwa ein bis zwei Stunden.
Und kurz vor dem Servieren
bestreue ich sie dann noch mit süßem Schnee.
Und wir machen noch mal Buttercreme.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ups.
>> SAMIRA: Das...
Ups!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ich nehme jetzt Glitzerschnee.
Sarah?
Voulez-vous manger le dessert?
>> SARAH: Ah oui.
Oui, oui, ma chérie!
>> SALLY: Entrer dans
>> SARAH: Oh!
Das ist hübsch!
>> SALLY: – irgendwas kitchen –
ma cuisine.
Entrer.
>> SARAH: Cuisine. Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Was heißt hübsch?
>> SALLY: Très bien?
>> SARAH: Très bien, das heißt gut.
Très chic!
>> SALLY & SARAH: Très chic!
>> SARAH: Très chic!
>> SALLY: C'est très chic. Oui.
>> SARAH: Je suis une baguette.
>> SALLY: Et je suis un perroquet.
Et
>> MURAT: Lasst euch nicht stören.
>> SALLY: Murat est un perroquet.
>> MURAT: Ich räume hier den Müll weg.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Murat, voulez-vous
manger le dessert?
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> SARAH: Was?
>> MURAT: Das kommt mir spanisch vor.
>> SALLY: Das bedeutet:
Möchtest du das Dessert probieren?
>> MURAT: Nein, nein. Macht ihr ruhig.
Ich mache alles sauber solange.
>> SARAH: Okay.
>> MURAT: Ich gehe. Ich bin im Garten.
>> SALLY: Das ist doch der perfekte Ehemann, oder?
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> MURAT: Ich bin im Garten.
>> SARAH: Vielleicht staubsaugt er auch gleich
>> SALLY: Ja, und er
>> SARAH: die Terrasse.
>> SALLY: putzt die Fenster.
Ja, er staubsaugt immer die Terrasse.
>> SARAH: Er ist der einzige Mensch,
der die Terrasse staubsaugt.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Boah!
Boah!
>> SALLY: Hm.
Délicieux!
>> SARAH: Magnifique!
Ich wollte auch erst délicieux sagen, aber...
>> SALLY: Hm.
Dann habe ich es dir vorweggenommen.
>> SARAH: Ja.
Die Mandeln, mmh!
>> SALLY: Echt lecker!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Die Creme, die Mandeln,
der Teig.
Ich kann gar nichts mehr sagen.
>> SARAH: Ich bin eh Fan von Brandteig.
>> SALLY: Hm. Ich bin so sprachlos.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ihr könnt die übrigens auch wunderbar vorbereiten.
Denn das Brandteiggebäck kann man
super vorbereiten und auch ungefüllt,
also in dem Zustand, auch einfrieren.
Dann habt ihr immer was auf Vorrat auch da.
Und dann
könnt ihr einfach euer Paris-Brest-Dessert zubereiten.
Ich muss sagen, ein ganzes schaffe ich vielleicht nicht.
>> SARAH: Hm, ist schon viel.
>> SALLY: Ist schon viel.
>> SARAH: Also so ein Stück reicht, glaube ich.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich muss auch sagen, vorhin war meine Butter echt sehr weich
und ich konnte sie gar nicht so richtig
maximal schaumig aufschlagen.
Wenn sie nicht ganz so weich ist,
geht es ein bisschen besser und man hat mehr Volumen
und dadurch dann eben auch weniger Masse
in so einem Ring.
Aber ich finde es so echt gut.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also so optisch, ja.
>> SARAH: Sieht auch so richtig schön aus
auf so einem Büfett.
>> SALLY: Oh ja!
>> SARAH: So ein süßes Dessertbüfett.
>> SALLY: Ist auch ein schönes Hochzeitsdessert.
>> SARAH: Auf Hochzeiten könnte es auch sein.
>> SALLY: Dann aber nicht goldenen Glitzerschnee,
sondern so weiß.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Och!
>> SARAH: So bei einer Hochzeitstorte unten.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Oh, wie schön!
Also probiert das Dessert gerne mal aus
und
>> SARAH: Sehr lecker!
>> SALLY: schreibt mir eure Kommentare.
Und wenn ihr euch weitere Desserts wünscht
oder Anregungen oder Ideen oder
irgendwas habt,
schreibt es mir einfach in die Kommentare.
Also das Rezept gibt es zum Nachlesen auf sallys-blog.de
und?
In der Sallys
>> SARAH: In der App.
>> SALLY: Welt App.
Tschüss!
>> SARAH: Die ihr hoffentlich alle abonniert habt.
>> SALLY: Heruntergeladen.
>> SARAH: Meine ich doch.
>> SALLY: Komm.
[Musik]